die außenministerin er pr berater wie
machen die das so erfolgreich mit ihrer
familie ihren kindern wie schaffen die
das und diese frage stellt sich jetzt
noch mehr den box ehemann daniel holte
flasche hat jetzt neuen job er heuert
als berater bei der berliner firma msl
germany an aufgabe dort strategische
kommunikationsberatung
er hatte zuvor noch gesagt dass wenn sie
in so ein spitzenamt kommt dann bleibt
er zu hause und jetzt eben doch der neue
job also
spitzenpolitik und gleichzeitig noch
relativ kleine kinder familie geht das
wie geht das auch darüber wollen wir
sprechen hier im studio mit dorothee bär
die ja in der spitzenpolitik ist im
kanzleramt gearbeitet hat als
staatssekretärin und vor allen dingen
familie hat kinder hat größte sie hat
sich bei guten morgen ganz einfach die
frage ja wir tun immer so als
funktioniert das alles top job im
journalismus top job in der wirtschaft
top job in der politik und gleichzeitig
voll für die familie da sein geht nicht
oder naja was heißt folder also ist es
ja niemand 24/7 immer da und das ist ja
auch eine mehr davon auszugehen dass es
früher anders war also wenn ich mich in
meinem wahlkreis auch mit älteren
bäuerinnen unterhalte die waren auch den
ganzen tag auf dem feld und hatten auch
nicht diesen anspruch so eine
innsbrucker zu sein wo das abendessen
ausgestochen wird in förmchen also das
ist natürlich schon eine perfektion die
teilweise vorgegaukelt wird in keiner
familie zu erfüllen ist in der politik
finde ich es ganz spannend dass sie mich
jetzt offensichtlich zu dem thema
eingeladen haben und keinen meiner
männlichen kollegen weil die nie dazu
befragt werden dass es immer noch auch
im jahr 2022 so eine sache über die
frauen sprechen müssten sprechen sollen
aber wo offensichtlich den männlichen
kollegen diese fragen die gestellt
werden ich würde auch den hole fly
stellen hiermit die einladung gerne für
uns gesund es liegt natürlich genau
daran dass es in den familien meistens
genauso organisiert ist also dass der
mann diese fragen im grunde gar nicht ja
an sich ran lässt weil wir ihn jetzt
völlig klar für die meisten
spitzenpolitiker heute nach wie vor
völlig klar dass es die frau halt zu
hause macht weiß ich nicht also meines
auch politiker und er wird trotzdem
nicht gefragt obwohl mal bei ihm genau
weiß was seine frau beruflich macht als
ich finde da hat sich in den letzten
jahren und auch jahrzehnten gar nichts
geändert jeder journalist immer dann
darauf anspricht und sagt frag doch mal
manzanilla würden machen tun tut dann
trotzdem keiner mir geht es gar nicht um
den mann von annalena baerbock sondern
tatsächlich auch über männer im
bundestag über männer in der
kommunalpolitik
dass da einfach auch mal ein anderes
bewusstsein noch geschaffen wird weil
die natürlich auch einen anspruch haben
gute väter zu sein bei ihren familien zu
sein und es geht ja auch nicht immer nur
um die quantität wie viele stunden am
tag bin ich da sondern tatsächlich um
die qualität und was mir auch wichtig
ist dass wir vielleicht mal ein bisschen
davon wegkommen
ja immer nur darüber zu sprechen nicht
nur dieses mann/frau themas und daneben
auch dieses thema wie macht sich diese
einzelne familie sondern dass es mehr
darum gehen muss wenn das modell was
jetzt die familie baerbock hole fleisch
lebt für die beiden passt und für die
kinder passt geht uns nichts an und so
ist es bei den müllers und meyers auch
also im idealfall hat jeder sein eigenes
familienmodell aber in deutschland ist
irgendwie jedes modell was die
nachbarfamilie lebt immer so die kritik
am eigenen modell ordens bei denen so
läuft bei uns anders da kann irgendwas
in mir hoch emotional ist hermann dem
bereich natürlich auch alles richtig
machen will und ich gebe ihnen
vollkommen recht ich glaube frauen
werden definitiv fragen gestellt die
männer nicht gestellt wird ich glaube
ich werde öfter gefragt wer passt auf
seine kinder auf ihren beide drei kinder
hier diese frage gestellt wird ich
glaube davon kann man wirklich ausgehen
trotzdem stellt man sich die frage gibt
es überhaupt eine vereinbarkeit zwischen
familie und karriere in der
spitzenpolitik denn man hat den eindruck
gewonnen auch zuletzt in der diskussion
und anne spiegel dass es überhaupt nicht
möglich ist dass die politik die
spitzenpolitik das oberste level gar
nicht die möglichkeit der vereinbarkeit
gibt ist also also die vorwürfe gegen
eine spiegel hatten überhaupt nichts mit
ihrer rolle als mutter zu tun sondern
das waren der sahara aussehens genau
also deswegen genau aber ich merkte
ihnen an dieser stelle ohne auf diesen
fall angehen aber dennoch als entbrannte
sich auch dort eine diskussion über die
vereinbarkeit lass mir diesen fall haus
weil es gibt mir wirklich darum dass wir
darüber sprechen sind diese top
positionen vereinbar wenn die familien
hat die für mann und frau also ich
glaube ja weil es natürlich immer eine
frage ist was habe ich dann auch im
rücken natürlich muss es auch in der
familien rückhalt geben das auch so ein
spitzen job ausgeübt werden kann also
wenn ich natürlich jetzt ein ehepartner
hat egal wie ob mann frau der nicht
dahinter steht das nicht akzeptiert dass
wenn jetzt eine sitzungswoche zu ende
ist dann also heute freitag wenn ich
heut' abend heim kommen ist
kreisdelegiertenversammlung in
haßfurt und morgen ist unser kleiner
parteitag in würzburg also wenn ich
akzeptiert wird dass auch am wochenende
termine stattfinden das auch am abend
das stattfinden kann oder wird jetzt bei
corona war es ja ein bisschen weniger
aber ist nicht der normalfall dann kann
es nicht funktionieren aber das stellt
sich natürlich bei ihnen genauso die
frage des stellt sich in der wirtschaft
die frage deswegen finde ich auch ja
vereinbarkeit familie und beruf klappt
in den meisten fällen relativ gut aber
karriere und familie ist schon noch mal
eine andere nummer weil da auch noch mal
ein ganz anderes commitment haltern auch
gefragt ist und deswegen hat sich in den
letzten jahren schon was getan auch im
bundestag ist es leichter geworden als
ich meine erste tochter bekommen habe
was nicht erlaubt den säugling mit in
den plenarsaal zu nehmen das war
schlichtweg verboten das haben wir dann
mit vielen kolleginnen aus dem laufe der
zeit dann auch durchgesetzt dass auch in
der anfangszeit wenn abends namentliche
abstimmungen es ist toll ist für das
kind natürlich auch nicht die optimale
lösung ich wollte ja meistens um der
abstimmung hat auf die lauter minuten
und davor was so man muss den
kinderwagen dann vom plenarsaal stehen
lassen im idealfall dem er in bordeaux
noch schlechter ich wollte auch einen
anderen punkt raus frau bär denn ich
finde die die frage ist immer ob das
überhaupt so geht das man dann seine
kinder noch sieht alles natürlich lässt
sich das irgendwie vereinbaren und
natürlich kann man so jemanden hin
organisieren der sich um die kinder
kümmert aber wenn man außenminister ist
wenn man wirtschaftsminister ist wenn
man in so einem top job in der politik
ist immer abends sitzung vor allen
dingen dann abends noch mal die partei
der wahlkreis usw alles spielt sich auch
ins wochenende ryan dunn ist doch ganz
ehrlich man hat eigentlich von der
kindheit seine eigenen kinder wenn ich
nicht an das wird auch total anmaßen es
wäre gut wenn so wenn es von außen so
gesehen wird ich sage auch immer zu den
leuten es schaut von außen viel
dramatischer oft aus weil wir natürlich
das muss man doch ganz offen sagen auch
in der privilegierten situation sind
wenn irgendwas ist dann sagt man dann
geht's halt jetzt mal nicht das kann
aber eine frau die nachtschicht macht im
krankenhaus nicht sagen ich lasse jetzt
einfach mal bei den patienten alles
stehen und liegen es kann der lkw fahrer
der drei wochen die norwegen route fährt
auch nicht machen da können sie das
machen wenn sie ein außenminister
besucht zum beispiel oder staatsbesuch
hier in deutschland haben und dann ist
halt in der kita gerade was dann ist in
der schule gerade was und dann ich
glaube dass das entscheidende ist und
das wissen wahrscheinlich die kinder von
annalena baerbock genauso wie von vielen
anderen kindern auch dass sie wissen
dass wenn wirklich was wichtiges ist man
immer alles stehen und liegen lassen
kann das geht ja in der muss die
gesellschaft vielleicht auch umdenken
wenn sie wollen dass eine frau bundes
außenministerin wird die auch mutter ist
dann muss es eben auch akzeptiert werden
und dann müssen auch bestimmte rituale
auch abgeschafft werden ich habe auch
irgendwann durchgesetzt dass ich
sonntagabend wenn es nicht ein
festgesetzter termin ist dass man nicht
termine macht die man auch an anderen
sechs tagen in der woche machen kann das
ist nicht leicht weil sich natürlich
über jahrzehnte gerade weil wir immer
noch in einem beruf arbeiten wo es viel
viel mehr männer gibt als frauen das so
durchgesetzt hat dass es an bestimmten
tagen zu bestimmten uhrzeiten dann so
sein muss aber andere termine die man
frei festsetzen kann haben wir natürlich
eine andere privilegierte situation als
das in den meisten berufen überhaupt der
fall ist also man kann eigentlich
schließen in der politik ist es nicht
anders wie in den meisten berufen außer
viel leichter ist natürlich die politik
auch noch eine gewisse vorbildfunktion
hat also es ist für mich zum beispiel
besonders ermutigend wenn der
vereinbarkeit klappt dann muss es doch
wir und alle anderen irgendwie auch
gehen kleine schritte werden da gemacht
ja und ich glaube ich man kann auch
große schritte gehen tatsächlich ein
bisschen mehr verständnis gegenseitig
dann wird es auch funktionieren und ich
bin mir sicher dass die annalena
baerbock auch eine sehr sehr gute mutter
ist
dorothea aber wir wollen mit ihnen
natürlich auch noch kurz über das große
thema dieses tages sperre gesprächen
boris becker der möglicherweise heute
tatsächlich in den knast muss heute wird
sein strafmaß verkündet dort in london
und wir schauen in diesen stunden in
seinem gesicht und sehen diese sorgen
natürlich vor diesem tag heute wir
erleben sie diesen fall boris becker
diesen fall eines helden hier in
deutschland also ehrlicherweise habe ich
mich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig mit
diesem fall beschäftigt weil ich ein
großer fußballfan bin denn es kommt
nicht ganz an nummer eins des interesses
aber wenn ich jetzt heute hier bei ihnen
die bilder gesehen habe ist natürlich
höchst emotional und da sind meine
gedanken er bei den kindern weil ich
glaube dass es für kinder die auch eine
ganz enge verbindung zu ihren eltern
haben in dem fall zum vater natürlich
schon eine ganz große bürde ist wenn man
nicht weiß ob man den vater am nächsten
tag noch sehen wird und ich hoffe dass
seine kinder insgesamt auch dann bei den
müttern oder bei anderen bezugspersonen
ganz stabiles umfeld haben dass sie gut
damit zurechtkommen danke herzlich
danke